[Music]
on this thursday night new crackdowns as
covet 19 cases
go up ontario's tougher targeted
measures
on private gatherings they must be a few
fries short of a happy meal of these
people
they know the rules and they just
blatantly ignore it
the virus spreads in schools across
canada how parents in one province are
helping
other parents stay informed one woman's
unimaginable heartbreak i have lost so
many parts of me
that make me a better person her tribute
to her husband and three children
all of whom were murdered plus canadians
to the rescue the reinforcements on
their way
to america's fire zone
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
what we've been warning about is now
happening in parts of ontario
tighter public health restrictions are
being reimposed on parts of that
province
because of the spread of covet 19.
starting tomorrow
in toronto peel region and ottawa the
number of people allowed at private
indoor gatherings will be reduced from
50 to 10
and the limit on private outdoor
gatherings will be slashed from 100
people to 25.
anyone caught breaking those rules will
face severe new consequences
a minimum ten thousand dollar fine for
party organizers
and seven hundred and fifty dollars for
each individual who attends the parties
this is a serious situation folks we
will throw the book
at you if you break the rules it's just
not fair
to the vast majority of people who are
following the rules it is
private parties where precautions like
masks and physical distancing are
ignored
that are driving up the number of new
cases and tracing contacts from people
who attend those parties
isn't easy which then drives community
spread
jeff semple reports on the new
restrictions officials hope
will put the brakes on rising infections
it was difficult
carling kolbuck and her fiance were
planning to get married in november with
250 guests
but those wedding bells won't be ringing
anytime soon
i kind of just knew it wasn't going to
happen ontario is now the latest
province to reimpose
covet 19 restrictions limiting outdoor
and indoor gatherings in ottawa toronto
and peel region where covet 19
cases are climbing it seems like it's
the right call to be honest it was i
think it was a little
little early for things to to move it
the way they did and i mean we're seeing
the result of that right now
this toronto university student lined up
for several hours for a covid19 test
after he received a smartphone alert
that he'd been exposed
most of the province's new cases are
young adults
health officials blaming private parties
and large family get-togethers
they must be a few fries short of a
happy meal these people because i just
don't i don't get it
they go out there they know the rules
and they just blatantly ignore it
those caught breaking ontario's rules
will now face hefty fines
750 dollars for guests and a minimum
10 000 fine for organizers the achilles
heel of all of these restrictions
is enforcement and how you go about
ensuring that people stick with it and i
think
the challenge with social gathering
restrictions is that it's um
it's it's a it's an activity that is
going to be caught quite infrequently
quebec and british columbia also
recently re-imposed
some restrictions targeting nightclubs
bars and banquet halls
but ontario's indoor gathering rules
will not apply to businesses
such as restaurants movie theaters and
gyms i think it's reasonable and i would
rather people
be you know at a restaurant where
there's distancing where there's
controls where there's measures whether
it's contact tracing than in a house
together
weddings which have sparked several
recent outbreaks will also be allowed
so long as they're held in banquet halls
or facilities with staff
enforcing restrictions still kohlbach
and her fiance have decided to wait
until november 2021 i think
my parents are probably just upset
they're gonna have to wait for a
grandchild another year
jeff temple global news toronto ontario
isn't the only province dealing with a
worrying spike in cases
quebec reported 499 new cases today
though nearly half of those
did happen over the last week in
montreal officials say there was a delay
in updating the database
in alberta there were 146 new cases
today
in bc 165 more people tested positive
that is a new daily record there are
positive cases
in schools including post-secondary
institutions in cities across the
country
in ontario at least 51 schools are now
reporting covet 19 cases in students or
staff
and one high school has been closed
fellows high school in pembroke
northwest of ottawa shut down after
three staff members tested positive
the third case was detected wednesday
and is linked to two previously
announced infections
their goal by closing the school is a
proactive precautionary measure and
testing all staff is to really
strategically locate isolate any
confirmed cases any links between those
cases
in order to then contact trace more
strategically and really
return the students to the school
setting that we all we all want for our
school communities
access to information is not consistent
but here is what we
do know about the impact the virus is
having on schools
bc alberta and saskatchewan are all
reporting cases in schools
in manitoba seven infections are linked
to one school in winnipeg
and are the first cases in manitoba
transmitted within a school
in quebec a private jewish school has
shifted to online classes for the next
two weeks because of an outbreak
there parents are watching closely
what's happening in schools one montreal
father is working to calm the anxiety by
crowdsourcing covid19 data we'll look at
how he's keeping kids and parents
informed
a little later in the newscast well it
can be difficult to keep up with
everything you need to know and those
looking for answers often spend hours
waiting in long lines to get tested for
covet 19.
policies seem to keep evolving too and
that includes on parliament hill
where questions are being raised around
who is responsible for enforcement
and whether staff and mps are safe
here's abigail beeman
the leader of the official opposition
says his family was part of these
hours-long ottawa lines for kovit 19
tests tuesday
eventually turned away the o'tools were
tested wednesday in gatineau via a new
service for mps and families through the
house of commons
it's one example of an ever evolving
copit 19 policy
global news has learned a new directive
will be issued before the house resumes
wednesday
it will address masks among other things
but there are no protocols in place in
terms of enforcement
the parliamentary protective service
tells global news it's not responsible
for policing coveted measures
and with one of their ranks testing
positive and o'toole and the block
quebecois leader both in isolation
some staff and mps tell global news
they're concerned whether everyone is
taking things seriously enough
i believe the protocols that are in
place there's been
are fine wayne easter says he hears
concerns from hill staffers the more mps
the greater the risk
i think there's a greater desire i guess
for people
to go to ottawa not necessarily to be in
the chamber
but to to do work from that point
in terms of that chamber there still
isn't a plan for how to proceed with
parliament
namely how to vote now here we are
down to the wire and we still don't have
a solution that is not safe for
parliamentarians it's not safe for the
people who work on the hill and it's not
safe for all canadians a roll call style
vote which is what we typically do in
the house of commons done
electronically you know that can be done
but the idea of just swiping
you know on an app that's a
very different story meanwhile ottawa
public health tells global news it's
investigating the parliament hill cases
as it does with any others
and so far they don't appear to be
linked they all acquired the virus in
their communities
and at this point this is not a hill
outbreak
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the virus is not vanishing today the
global numbers reached a new milestone
according to world domiter and johns
hopkins university there are now more
than 30
million confirmed cases of covet 19. the
bulk of them are in the u.s
about 1 6 of cases are in europe and
they are rising
last week alone 300 000 people across
europe tested positive
far exceeding numbers reported at the
start of this pandemic
as crystal gomencing explains the world
health organization says the new case
numbers should serve
as a wake-up call for the world
people coughing a common sound in covet
19
testing lines around the world this is
the third day
trying to get a test yesterday we missed
it by one person
so we got sent away long lines for tests
and new regulations are something people
will have to get used to 1.5 million
people living in northeastern england
are
facing tighter rules in newcastle for
example
meeting people outside of your household
bubble in private settings
is banned pubs and restaurants must
close at 10
but then can offer takeout service
rising infections across
europe are fueling concerns with 11
291 cases new targeted restrictions
are expected in some areas of spain
friday
france set a new three-month record high
with 10 593 cases
the uk is lower with just over three
thousand
it's careless and reckless to under
estimate this virus
and we do it at our own expense the
obvious impact are deaths from the
populations that are oldest and with
pre-existing conditions
but again we're learning more and more
young people
can have long-term implications for
their own well-being and health
the younger demographic needs to be
drawn into the public health
conversation
as they're seen as the greatest
spreaders of the virus
but experts say skeptics must also be
reached
it's not the time to shame people
because they don't wear masks
it's we need to persuade them that this
is
what you're doing to help the older
generation or
help your health system help you all
your society you know go through this
pandemic fatigue may have set in long
ago
but we've seen how quickly this virus
can spread
krystal gavinson global news london
the u.s still has the most cases of
cobit 19 and the most deaths of any
country in the world
and it has a president who lied to the
american people about the severity of
the situation even though he knew the
facts
and now president trump is misleading
the public about a vaccine
he's claiming a vaccine could be ready
within three to four weeks
tying it to his re-election efforts and
he's pressuring top government doctors
and scientists to support his
unrealistic timeline jackson proskow
reports
a vaccine may be a way out of the
pandemic
proving it's safe and getting it to
every american will be a monumental task
if you're asking me when is it going to
be generally available to the american
public
i think we're probably looking at third
late second quarter third quarter 2021
that dose of reality hasn't sat well
with president donald trump
it's just incorrect information who sees
a vaccine
as inoculation against his own political
woes
it could be announced in october trump
who has no medical background his
promising inoculations will be widely
available
just in time for november's election far
sooner than any health
expert i would say that we will start
distributing it immediately
but when the president kind of spews
this magical thinking
unfortunately it actually takes hold
with some people because people don't
know how to distinguish what's
lies or magical thinking while several
vaccines are in stage 3 clinical trials
there's worry about rushing approval for
political purposes
something pharmaceutical companies say
they won't do
i trust vaccines i trust
scientists but i don't trust donald
trump
the rhetoric is having an impact on
public confidence a majority of
americans
52 percent say they do not trust what
the president has to say about a vaccine
only 26 percent do that same poll found
just 39 percent of americans willing to
accept a vaccine right now
part of the problem may be trump's own
history of false claims about the virus
the virus will disappear it will
disappear
the president has admitted to
downplaying the threat and keeping
critical information quiet
now he's asking americans to trust that
he can bring the pandemic to an
end jackson prosko global news
washington on the west coast of the
united states canadian firefighters are
joining crews battling the fierce
wildfires there
dozens of people have died thousands of
homes
are gone this is all that's left in my
house
230 firefighters mainly from bc and
alberta head to oregon tomorrow
they'll join up to 50 so-called overhead
personnel supervisors specialists and
technical experts from ontario manitoba
alberta and bc
who left today this season's wildfires
are significantly more intense along the
u.s west coast than anything that's
happened
over the past two decades police in
british columbia have arrested a man
believed to be responsible for setting
fire to an historic
pier this four-alarm
fire broke out at new westminster's pier
park on sunday
toxic smoke filled the air and the
boardwalk was destroyed
the suspect has been released on bail
police expect arson charges
to be laid colleagues of russian
opposition leader alexei navalny say
they've discovered how he was poisoned
with the nerve agent
novichok a german lab says it detected
novotrak on an
empty water bottle his team picked up
from the siberian hotel room where
navalny was staying
before he fell critically ill his team
says this suggests navalny was poisoned
there and not at the airport
he became ill on a russian domestic
flight on august 20. he was hospitalized
and later transferred to a berlin
hospital where he's now
recovering navalny's family believes the
kremlin ordered the poisoning
the kremlin denies that a wife and
mother
buries her family in no way shape or
form can i believe that good will come
out of this tragedy
it can't the funeral for a murdered
father and three children
many families have had to find ways to
say goodbye to loved ones in this
pandemic but
few funerals are as heartbreaking as one
that took place
today in oshawa ontario four members of
one family a father
and three children were laid to rest and
the mother from that family the sole
survivor of the shooting rampage that
killed them
gave the eulogy
loretta traynor still recovering from
gunshot wounds herself arrived in a
wheelchair
she spoke alongside her only surviving
son sam
he wasn't home when the gunman opened
fire inside their house
on september 4th they were the best of
me
but with sam beside me and all of you
supporting me
i have hope that those parts of chris
bradley adelaide and joey
those parts that make up the best parts
of me
can find their way back in
police identified the gunman as
48-year-old mitchell lappa the brother
of loretta he killed four members of the
family before killing himself
police are still investigating the
motive
we'll be back in a moment
you're watching global national
since the beginning of the pandemic the
federal government has poured billions
of dollars into programs to support
individuals and businesses
there's one program though that's cost
nothing so far
because it hasn't been used it's called
the large employer
emergency financial facility or leaf
michael couture explains why it's failed
to take off
we are establishing a large employer
emergency financing facility
it was a big name for a big program that
so far
has provided no results announced in the
spring the usefulness of leaf as it's
known
is uncertain prime minister justin
trudeau said the goal was for the
government to be the lender of last
resort
but it hasn't been used even by the most
in need
we see traffic is going to be down 72
percent by the end of this year it's
really just devastating
with travel restrictions across the
globe canadian airports are suffering
the canadian airports council represents
54
airports across the country but none
have applied for the leaf
despite projecting losses of 4.5 billion
dollars in 2020
and 21. it's not on terms better than
they can get in the marketplace airports
it's like being in a fully functioning
lifeboat
they're not going to drop you know get
into a leaky inflatable
the interest rates on leaf loans are
five percent to start and increase to
eight percent
after a year bank interest rates are
much
lower leaving some to question the goal
of the program the primary intent may
have been just to drive a little bit
more confidence
and just to show that the money is there
the government is willing to backstop
firms if necessary but only in the most
extreme cases
officials at the finance department say
they have received more than a dozen
applications which are being evaluated
quote
to ensure they are in the best interests
of canadian taxpayers
while also securing the cooperation of
existing creditors
instead some believe the government
should focus on other programs that have
actually worked what the government
needs to concentrate on is the uh the
waste subsidy
program and though there hasn't been a
big enough take-up they should eliminate
the problems with that program and that
refocusing of aid could be part of the
throne speech next week the government
has promised a bold ambitious plan for
the country
while taking care of canadians during
the ongoing pandemic
mike licouter global news ottawa
frustrated father next one man's efforts
to track covid19 in quebec schools
parents across the country are anxiously
keeping an eye on what's happening in
schools
information on covid19 infections isn't
always easy to get and so
a montreal father decided to take
matters into his own hands
as mike armstrong explains he set up a
website to collect
track and map kovid 19 cases in quebec
schools
your website exploded it really did i
mean
it is far beyond anything olivier dr
expected what started as a little pet
project in his spare time
has taken over all of his spare time due
is putting in
several hours a day running his website
but it's getting traction
i can tell you over 2.3 million page
views
so that's quite a lot of traffic for a
dad in this basement
uh working on a website yes deroy's site
tracks quebec schools that have had at
least
one case of covid19 as of thursday his
list was at 297
that's about one school in 10. the
information he uses is public when a
school has a case it has to send out a
letter notifying parents
well through duroyah's site parents
notify him
you vet the submissions that come to
your site to make sure they're real
yes so what i do is when the submission
comes in i contact
individuals that submitted the case and
then i asked them for a copy of the
letter from the government or public
health that confirms the positive case
now the whole thing was born of
frustration the way his daughters were
starting the school year
and he noticed there was no way to
follow what was happening in quebec
schools
well dr roy's list basically forced the
quebec government to make its own
and that effort has come under a lot of
criticism there are about 60
schools on deway's list that aren't on
the governments
it's had trouble keeping up i don't know
if you've made any friends in the
government at this point
i don't know if i've made any friends
i'm i'm hoping that as a
as a concerned citizen i've made many
friends outside of government
dwight says he's been blown away by the
reaction and it's spreading there's an
advocacy group in alberta tracking cases
in schools there
and another in toronto tracking cases
nationally duane's hoping provincial
governments find a way to give parents
as much information as possible
not just the number of schools but how
many cases and the root cause of the
transmission
he'll keep up the pressure in the
meantime but hopes to shut his sight
down as soon as possible
working and raising two daughters is
plenty
mike armstrong global news montreal
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is a beautiful sunny day
in whitehorse it's still summer right
for another couple of days
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
and i hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you